thank you
[Music]
all right everybody Welcome to a very
special episode of the careful boys
where today we are going to be talking
about Maui Maui Joe take it away
Hawaiian native sort of you you have
more ties to Hawaii than I do you're
born there all the time no it was not
born there my sister was born there my
parents met and got married there I was
conceived there and I got married there
yeah so we both have relatives there
both have hello relatives there but I
was born here I was also born here so
why the butt you were conceived in Maui
Hey Joe were you conceived in Maui you
weren't conceived in Maui I was
conceived in Maui that's pretty cool man
I'm actually very upset about that that
I was conceived there and my mom was
there for eight months and then came
over in a month on the ninth month I
think in the eighth or ninth month and
then came over so you could have been a
local boy but I couldn't I could have
and I lost all my Hawaii privilege yep
chakras all the time pigeon yeah you
know I think we're pigeon would be cool
do you have a good pigeon accent no
try listen try listen no try listen say
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
[Laughter]
uh it's crazy because
so I um I wasn't planning on stopping by
but I had I missed a flight so I had to
do a connector at Maui and then like I
mean we've been watching all the footage
and everything but it's so different
watching it on the phone versus like
seeing it on the plane just looking down
and going like what the [__] like the
whole area is much bigger than what you
can imagine because it's just the whole
the whole town of Lahaina is gone like
completely gone I don't know if you guys
ever been there ever never sure yes I've
always wanted to go but I got this
tattoo there in Lahaina town in Lahaina
yeah wow that's a cool time
yeah it's it's crazy because
um I'll go there like every every year
and just being in a place where all of a
sudden it's just like disappeared out of
like overnight I was like what the [__]
like how and then how fast it went away
that's crazy I heard on um on breaking
points either ever watch Breaking points
no they were talking about it and they
were saying that they were having
malfunctions in the in the the fire of
the the what you call it the the water
irrigation system no they shut it off
that's what they were saying yeah not
malfunctioned they just turned it off
they're like that's too much water
you're using
wait to stop the fire yeah well okay do
you think that's fishy that's fishy bro
there's a lot to it so Maui's already
got
um they're already in a drought
they're already dirty like don't have
enough water right and then um a couple
years ago it was so bad
that when people are visiting they were
telling the locals limit your water use
because there's so many people remember
that coming in right now and then like
you're just using too much water so
their water reserves were low
and then so
um while they were fighting the fire
uh the fire department was saying like
their water just
got shut off
so in the middle of fighting the fire
like they ran out of there's just no
more water there's footage of people
like with garden hoses yeah just trying
to protect their homes and then the
water shut off
yeah that's [__] that's not Fishy Stuff
huh fishy business
I think for people that don't know all
right we gotta go through the sequence
of what went down because there's some
people saying that it's like a [__]
weather attack and then there's like so
I'll give you the crazy crazy I heard
there's some crazy conspirations some
better sound very reasonable and also
and I'll show you though and I'll tell
you the reason right crazy is that um
they said that it's uh it's uh we have
these
weapons that could manipulate the
weather
right and then so they were testing it
out on Maui to Target that area because
they want to wipe out that whole Prime
real estate and turn it into a 15-minute
City okay that's the that's the most
outlandish one and it was a coordinated
effort yeah what's a 15-minute City like
a smart City yeah like a smart city and
it's like a modern 15 minutes
but anyways there so that that whole
Camp believes that it's a coordinated
effort by the government everybody
because there are a lot of weird [__]
right so for one it's like
um they say that it was planned because
uh you know they didn't even sound the
alarm and Hawaii has all the every once
a month they test it on every island
when you hear that what like it gets
really loud like a [__] bomb is about
to come is that a tsunami alarm it is it
is but it's meant for
urgent it's an emergency alarm right
that alarm didn't go off that was the
first thing everyone asked they're like
why didn't the alarms go off he's in
charge has now resigned
exactly very interesting and that guy
was off the island conveniently and he
was in a hotel seminar with FEMA about
environmental disasters
wow how coincidentally right beaver's
gonna all these conspiracy theories are
gonna say all this [__] coincidence
they're gonna think I was [__] around
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot so
so I'm just going blush reading [__]
Elementary School yeah I'm just going
from
the wildest [__] to the most normal [__]
right so that's the wildest [__] the
most normal [__] is
um it it was extremely [__] windy
like nothing I've ever experienced here
in California it was like 100 mile winds
so [__] windy that
um roofs and and phone lines and
everything were falling down on Oahu it
wasn't as bad but it was still very
freaking windy
so
um if you see footage of before the fire
on Lahaina like there's there's this
street called Front Street that's where
like the main street is where all the
shops are there's people like walking
around town and they're showing you like
trees that fell down and um roofs of
whole entire buildings just gone because
the wind blew it off so a lot of the
businesses were closed that day and then
a lot of people weren't walking around
so maybe it could have been worse but a
lot of people just weren't in the town
already
and then
um Lahaina always has fires during the
summer like or just Maui in general
whenever I'm there there's always like a
brush on fire or something and it's
usually up country meaning like it's on
the other side of the island where
there's like these grassy Hills
so there was a fi there's a footage of a
guy where uh he's recording this little
fire because a telephone
um I mean not a telephone the Electrical
uh Powerline yeah the power line it fell
and at the end it was like like that
right so they got this patch of grass on
fire and then uh the fire truck came and
he's like they're like fighting it and
then it flew on the other side and it
got the other side all lit up so like
that's where everyone's like recording
it you see the beginning of it and it
starts from up the hill and then so
apparently by the morning like the fire
department says that it's contained
meaning like if they dealt with the fire
but there are other fires around the
island so there were like Three Fires
going on at the same time another area
called Kula which is like you know like
a 30 minute drive or more
that was burning too so that town was
burning this was burning it was all it
was just a [__] of crazy and then
the fire I guess was moving like a mile
a minute so it was like when you see
holy [__] it's crazy like you'll see one
house on fire and then like when they're
recording it the second house is already
getting on fire 30 seconds later so it's
moving it's moving fast yeah
and then when the fire went
um when the fire happened the police and
everyone was directing traffic but I
think the [__] that happened was
because of the high winds a lot of
um phone like Towers or like what do you
call it like those uh poles or like
trees all these things were falling down
and blocking traffic and you'll see this
too like cars are coming up and then
they're like whoops and then they're
trying to turn out everyone's trying to
leave
and then there's cops like directing
traffic Into the Fire they're like oh
you can't come this way you got to go
this way because the roads block up
there so it was just such a crazy
[__] and then with all the Flames
coming in I was like this is this is
wild because when you watch the footage
none of the cops are on the loudspeakers
saying like get out of your homes
there's no warning no one knew anything
and then like that's when everyone was
just like oh [__] we got to get out of
here but the weird thing is there wasn't
like a chaos of people like trying to
run over each other or nothing it was
quiet and it was just people like trying
to get away yeah
oh [__] because the the footage of uh
the car burning like the or like the
burnt cars and
likable that so the reason why they
couldn't get out was because the roads
are blocked like right by the by the
beach like that yeah yeah so there was
several roads you'll you'll see this too
if you watch the before like before the
fire came and people just recording the
crazy wins there's already like palm
trees and stuff down blocking the road
and debris and whatever yeah
and then so that's what built uh blocked
off the traffic there's actually
um One Main Road that's out that goes
out of town it's only one yeah so it's
like one in one out
so there was two ways to escape one is
going up
um
toward like Kaanapali where so one is
going north one is going south right and
a lot of people will go south
but then that road that's actually the
corner of where the first fire started
so they already blocked that early in
the morning
yeah so everyone that was going this way
was like getting screwed so everyone's
stuck go this way yeah so it was like a
big cluster [__] and in the little
streets too if they try to do local like
it was like you know different you know
Street blockages and I said and I think
like they're saying the last moments is
when people were blocked and then they
were just like oh [__] we just got to
jump in the water because it was coming
from up the hill going down like this
those videos are crazy yeah
they said that uh so far at least 111
people have been killed but only 10
people have been identified oh my gosh
oh my god dude I saw the police chief
talking about it he was talking about
how we have to get DNA samples from all
the the
burnt up ashes from the bodies right and
they said it's taking a long time yeah
also the resources to do that quickly
isn't going to be high in a smaller town
a total of 58 of the burned area of
Lahaina so far they're using [__] ton of
like cadaver dogs and stuff like that
but it was 30 cadaver dogs
and they only as of now they only did
like 25 percent of the town it's a big
area dude because
so the the official count is over 2 000
structures
are completely gone so imagine that's
like if one person's in in one structure
that's over 2 000 people the official
official I think missing persons count
right now is like uh 1300 1300. that's
the official missing person a couple
days ago I heard it was like a thousand
or something damn maybe like a couple
weeks ago actually what do you think of
all those like Tick Tock detectives that
are like what are people wearing a bunch
of graphs and saying a laser shot down
and that was a that was that that was a
launch they they debunked that that
laser it wasn't Maui there was some
other place and it was going up because
it was a it was like a launch it was I
think it was California or something it
was launch of a rocket but they debugged
it dude there's so many like
disrespectful theories on like why the
what were some of the hottest ones you
saw
that's that's the main one is that they
think it's a government ploy to steal
the land but then the the cause is all
these different like space age uh
weaponry
nah I think
so this is my honest thoughts about that
the government the Hawaii state
government is really incompetent I don't
think they can pull anything off well
like it's really bad that a lot of
Hawaiians don't say that yeah no it's
shockingly bad like to me it makes more
sense that all of this was a a extreme
[__] of one after the other bad
decisions yeah yeah and then no
leadership and like just everyone was
caught off guard is uh is Maui getting
any federal aid yet because I heard a
lot of times so buy it by I think Biden
says one house each member of the
household is going to get 700 bucks
right yeah if you if you so if it's 2
000 structures it's like what 700 it's
like one point less than two million and
also it's like these people who lost
their homes like I really hope I mean
this might probably happen but
developers are going to look at this as
an opportunity I heard people are
already getting calls they're gonna be
forced out of the place that they
that's the talk right now is everyone's
trying to figure out
um how to stop that
um that's so hard right you know that
MMA girl that that's leading the the
Illuminator yeah so her fund I think
it's at like two 2.5 mil right now and
um she says that all of that is going to
go to the community to make sure that
they can keep their property going into
that yo don't answer that yeah it's a
reporting that investors and Realtors
are trying to capitalize on the
wildfires to purchase land from the
locals the Hawaii governor Josh Green
said we're not going to allow it but I
mean who knows yeah when money is
involved that's the crazy thing is you
don't need a government Ploy for that to
happen that's just naturally what always
happens after disasters is that people
come in there's uh scoop it all up
they're trying to pass this uh I don't
know if it's a bill I mean I guess it's
like a request for funds but so FEMA
apparently is broke and in this relief
disaster relief thing that they're
trying to pass through
um
the request is 12 billion
for Maui
but 24 for Ukraine oh that's good so so
people are talking about that like why
wait why are we throwing 24 billion to
Ukraine or whatever how about we help
our 24 billion in addition to the
already 12 to Maui so they're like oh
yeah yeah yeah they're so it's like a
disaster relief you know how they pack
these things in with like yeah with
extra stuff right so that's I guess the
conversation right now is like wait what
like people are starting to get real
salty about Ukraine now yeah no for real
I'd be mad too especially if I lived on
Maui and dude I'd be [__] pissed
because I thought especially if I lived
on Melania and I was Ukrainian
so confused I'd be so mad if you're
Russian
someone calculated how much it would
cost to rebuild Lahaina to what it was
before 1.7 million 5.5 billion yeah if
it was like 12 billion yeah dude from
the 700. but how much how much do you
bet I mean I I assume that the 12
billion is not even gonna act that's
what I'm saying like it's gonna be
funneled other ways what's the
likelihood that a lot of that money will
be corrupted by Hawaiian officials like
a lot well it could be corrupted by 4.9
million FEMA of the feds like we don't
know right like by the time it gets to a
hand of like a person that actually was
a victim of it it's probably seven
hundred dollars yeah yeah that's so sad
have you talked to anybody from out like
recently that lives on Maui of like
what's happening like boots on the
ground my friend my friend uh he's a b
boy he lives on Maui he lives in in
Lahaina and his his house got spared
holy [__] whoa he got he was like
there's only a few structures that very
very about the church right that's very
very few so he had he had a bunch of
people uh live in his house like
everyone's staying that's cool bro
really cool so it's cool to see how the
community like comes together you know
like that's really [__] tight right
they're not looting each other and [__]
like they're just cool everyone's making
sacrifices driving across town some
family man loading up the giant trucks
and like that [__] is really cool dude
that's another thing too because like so
you know how Biden was talking about
FEMA Red Cross is there there's like 10
000 beds or there's all there's all this
stuff right but no one
sees FEMA or they don't know where
redclaw that's what I keep hearing I
keep hearing that the locals are not
seeing any federal aid and it's just
like it's just us yeah it's just the
locals that are doing right the day
after it happened
um my friend flies Air Cargo to Inner
Island and so their company uh decided
to give a bunch of water for the First
Responders so when they got there and
then they're like hauling all this
equipment and then
um they said that like female Red Cross
was just holding all the pallets in one
of the storage things and they're just
like yeah don't bring any more stuff we
don't have a way to transport it oh cool
yeah but
it sounded crazy because he said that
when they flew in if it seemed like a
war zone because there were a bunch of
people like around the airport just
around the fence and then they were
yelling like let us on let us on help us
get back yeah and they're like we can't
take everybody so it's like yeah
yeah my sister-in-law is talking about
how they might have to move off the
island because again like you know work
in their what they normally do oh they
live they live on Maui yeah it might be
compromised to a point where it's like
you know what's your guys's opinion on
like how like there's a lot of people
that are like filming tourism and like
how dare they still come here and [__]
but even though the other side of that
is like some of the people that provide
tourism are residents
hawaiian-born residents of line that are
like well we want to still make some
money like
yeah I think that's you know what's the
call what's the card about it I was like
[__] pieces of [__] who would go over
there during this time but then you
think about the other side yeah they're
like ashamed but it's like dude there's
V there's a lot of videos now of local
residents that like rely on it and then
they're like dude like why do you what
are you guys doing they made a good
point though because they're like like
Jason Momoa and like like all these
celebrities like you guys don't have to
worry about money and you're telling
people to not come and it's like yeah
but what about us and I was like damn
because at first it's for real like we
saw that group snorkeling yeah the
snorkeling like the [__] like people
just died in those Waters and you're
snorkeling there the next day yeah
that's that's okay I see a [__] hand
you know like oh [__] dude but if that's
like an actual Hawaiian business and the
guy running that boat is a native like
dude then is it so bad yeah I mean they
they'll it's like I don't know what the
right answer is I don't live there you
know like it's like it's like imagine
the tattoo artist who lives there it's
like it's not like locals are just
getting new tattoos every day you know
what I mean you just need people to come
in so it's like if that's the best
version of support it's like that's a
double show you can't get mad at a
tourist in a sense you know because like
like we talked about in the other video
so much of Maui's economy is tourism
yeah so much for me I'm like I know
people are angry right but then
sometimes they just get mad at the first
thing they see that's annoying and
upsetting yeah but I'm like
at the end of the day your government
didn't take care of you like they struck
up on so many like the police department
[__] up the fire department well I
don't think they [__] up but they ran
out of water like that's so stupid
that's crazy so like
and then whoever shut off the water is
[__] stupid yeah like what happened
there yeah and then you have the
emergency response Guy saying he had a
conference saying like oh you know what
um I have no regrets about not sounding
the alarm
the people of Maui were so stupid that
if they turn on the tsunami alarm they
would run uphill I don't like those I
don't like those uh those
generalizations the thing is everyone's
told that that's an emergency alarm not
a tsunami alarm and if you go on the
website everybody's just underlining
that it's for wildfires specifically too
so then like
that's why he resigned because whatever
and then just there's so much
incompetence every step of the way that
I feel like
man that's who you should be talking to
there were um their environmental groups
that kept pushing the government to like
deal with the brush fires and certain
things they they did a survey on the
probabilities of how dangerous it would
be and this was years ago they said you
guys gotta you guys gotta do these steps
to modernize your town you got to bury
your phone lines you got to bury the
electrical wires you got to do all this
[__] but like they didn't do any of it
so then now it's kind of like
to me it's like
who like the tourism is like that's I
get
that but that doesn't solve your future
issues like it's really
being a like making a government
accountable yeah the crazy thing too is
like how many articles have we already
seen where like none of that's addressed
none of the causes that could have you
know made sense or addressed and it just
says global warming yeah yeah yeah yeah
and nothing else is like talked about
like ways that the local government
failed the people for the resources that
they're paying out of their taxes or
like none of them guys that people are
going to use this to support some sort
of agenda or narrative that they
typically do it seems like such an easy
cop-out for corruption to like continue
yeah yeah because it people get angry
and they'll just latch on to whatever
sounds like they're the enemy but it's
like you're getting distracted you're
like oh Global Warming see that's why I
[__] these guys like [__] conservatives
or whatever right and then the other
side's like yeah [__] liberals because
of this this and this and then it's like
[__] tourists and I'm like
you're angry at the wrong people that
have no power yeah yeah they're not
gonna that's true yeah that's very true
and then some people are like yeah if
this was a Republican government it
would be this and that I'm all like no
it's just there's nepotism and then
there's corruption and I think certain
states have more of that than others
right yeah yeah and the longer it goes
uncontested the stronger right yeah
because the emergency guy that resigned
he wasn't even qualified for that role
he took like a he took like one seminar
or some [__] he has no prior experience
as a first responder to anything damn so
it's like dude there's all kinds of
[__] going on so it's mostly
incompetence you think a hunch I think
it's a thousand percent like it's
probably the biggest uh yeah you drop
the ball in your emergency room yeah and
you continue to drop the ball as you're
running a government and then these
things happen it's like yeah yeah
I think it's incompetence from
leadership and and just yeah they were
overwhelmed yep
do we have direct links to give money to
oh you know I'll drop a Google link here
um like what I was doing was giving
direct to families yeah and a lot of our
fan base is actually either from Maui or
they have family in Lahaina and what I
just told them to do is send me your
GoFundMe directly and then I'll fund
that and so that's what I've been doing
yeah send it but uh if you guys just
want a whole list of helping out
families directly because some of these
organizations not on this list but you
know like for example big organizations
a lot of that money just goes to admin
fees it doesn't go directly to the
people that need help they need help
directly yeah and I would say like it
might be better to just pick a family
that needs your help and also these even
if they do get government help or
whatever it doesn't cover things like
funeral fees if a lot of members of
their family pass it doesn't cover
Hospital fees if they got hurt and
injured from maybe the smoke or all
kinds of other things so they're gonna
need cash
send some money
foreign